sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales rusia
enfrenta una nueva oleada de condena
internacional y señalamientos de
crímenes de guerra cometidos
presuntamente por su ejército luego de
que ucrania denunciara el hallazgo de
los cuerpos de cientos de civiles en la
localidad de butch a las afueras de kiev
el presidente ucraniano asegura que se
trata de un genocidio y el de eeuu joe
biden opinó que vladimir putin debería
ser juzgado por crímenes de guerra desde
el kremlin han negado toda
responsabilidad en los hechos y afirman
que se trata de un montaje orquestado
por radicales ucranianos nuestro
periodista en el terreno bolívar crack
visitó mucha una zona que fue testigo de
intensos combates y de la huida de la
mayoría de su población también fue el
hogar del único an225 jamás construido
este gigantesco avión de carga orgullo
de los ucranianos también resultó
destruido desde los primeros días de los
combates
junto a los restos del avión más grande
del mundo el ministro de defensa de
ucrania premia a las tropas
con el límite y rubén con el aeródromo
de host o mail uno de los primeros
lugares ocupados por rusia a finales de
febrero vuelve a estar bajo control
ucraniano el pueblo de quien reza por
usted y por que echemos a esos infames
de todo nuestro país desde el fondo de
mi corazón gracias sin embargo la
celebración es silenciosa la batalla se
ganó a un costo enorme
no no puedo decirte cómo fue
esto no es la victoria todavía es sólo
el comienzo la victoria será cuando
todos se hayan ido cuánta pena las
ciudades de este distrito quedaron
devastadas hasta el domingo por la tarde
se habían encontrado más de 400
cadáveres de civiles en la región de
kiev el recuento final será mayor pero
este barrio parece haberse salvado de lo
peor de la violencia no arde también
los rusos estuvieron aquí fueron de casa
en casa buscando algo no sé qué buscaban
cierto juego de reseña hace una semana
desde el 4 de marzo no tenemos
electricidad ni agua ni gas así que
cocinamos nuestra comida aquí fuera
la falta de electricidad también
significa que no hay noticias así que
parte de la tarea de los soldados aquí
ahora es informar
[Música]
los rusos dicen que quieren establecer
su control sobre toda la región de
doñetsk lugansk
así que habrá una escala allí si
inevitablemente pero les hemos
bombardeado tanto que sus unidades ya no
están preparadas para el combate esta
columna de avance fue destruida hace
tres semanas los cuerpos de los soldados
rusos aún yacen esparcidos en los
alrededores propios ocupantes rusos
intentaban utilizar esta carretera para
llegar aquí desde justo mail a través de
espn hicimos explotar el puente y las
unidades del ejército ruso en la guardia
nacional así como sus vehículos por lo
que este es el lugar donde se detuvo
definitivamente su avance sobre kiev
aunque están orgullosos de esta victoria
y se sienten aliviados de que la región
de kiev esté ahora libre de las tropas
rusas los ucranianos también se
preguntan cuál podría ser la venganza de
los rusos las fuerzas rusas continúan su
repliegue en el norte de ucrania
asegurando que la primera fase de lo que
ellos han denominado como una operación
militar especial ha cumplido con sus
objetivos archiv la segunda ciudad del
país ha sido fuertemente golpeada por
los bombardeos
afectado a la población civil muchos
residentes han huido o pasan los días
refugiados bajo tierra pero algunos
siguen resistiendo a pesar de los
peligros los reporteros de nuestros
canales hermanos en francés e inglés
catherine north stream come volumen y us
bar a vida se reunieron con algunas de
estas personas que viven en la línea de
fuego mientras los combates en torno a
jarquín continúan
al norte dejar kit de sal típica es una
zona desierta la artillería rusa
bombardea a esta zona residencial día y
noche
todos los habitantes han huido o casi
la foto
sólo algunos cuantos como luzmila han
decidido quedarse
el 23 de marzo un misil alcanzó su
edificio
ah
otros nacimientos de la fiesta
pues ivan basso que
sobre ti
esta familia ha huido a un lugar más
seguro pero vienen al barrio todos los
días por solidaridad
aquí la lluvia de bombardeos de rusia
salpica la vida cotidiana en heart que
ya se ha cobrado la vida de al menos 300
civiles
cada vez que hay una alerta luz mila de
75 años se refugia en el sótano que
comparte con su vecino sanya
la vida
esta noche
muchísimas
luzmila era profesora de música lleva
cinco semanas encerrada en su refugio
por fin una tregua
el vecino aprovecha para llevarnos al
quinto piso
donde cayó el misil
sanya es de origen ruso
esta guerra entre hermanos lo supera
werner sinn yo soy ingeniero nieto
ni huevos ni evolución ya sabemos que
los grandes gay mitchell usuarios
seleccionar mala watson
alquiler
el hotel
pero nada de baches
esta vez los disparos vienen del lado
ucraniano
los enfrentamientos continúan cerca de
jarquín en los últimos días las fuerzas
ucranianas afirmaron haber lanzado una
contraofensiva y haber logrado recuperar
parte del territorio al este pero no
todo eso error en jarquín a pesar de la
muy difícil situación que vive la ciudad
una pareja decidió enviar un mensaje de
amor y residencia celebrando su boda en
medio de los escombros que deja más de
un mes de guerra nuestros reporteros
café y noris 30 luego me voló en grúa y
hasta la vida los acompañaron en el
proceso
en medio de la devastación de un
edificio bombardeado en el centro de
jarquín un rayo de esperanza y una
imagen de amor
los recién casados anthony nastia han
decidido visibilizar su boda entre las
ruinas que seguirás cogiendo de la mano
cuando sea mayor para llamar la atención
sobre la situación de su ciudad golpeada
por la artillería rusa y misma creada
a pesar de todas las atrocidades
cometidas en kharkiv ucrania todavía hay
un espacio para el amor
y para la bondad y la calidez solo este
tipo de sentimientos pueden ayudarnos a
sobrellevar la situación y a vencer
horror
la ceremonia tuvo lugar en el metro
donde miles de personas de jarquín se
han refugiado de los misiles y la
artillería desde los primeros días de la
guerra
es un raro interludio de alegría
esto es para siempre sí
[Aplausos]
gloria a ucrania
el alcalde de jarquín es un invitado de
honor ha estado trabajando para mantener
los servicios esenciales en
funcionamiento durante la ofensiva
a pesar de la ofensiva militar y de los
constantes bombardeos de los agresores
rusos sobre la ciudad dejar que el
pueblo ha encontrado fuerza y valentía
conocimos a antonio y nastic a el día
antes de su boda en un centro de
voluntarios que distribuye alimentos y
medicamentos
ambos son médicos él es dentista y ella
enfermera como muchos otros ahora
trabajan incansablemente en el esfuerzo
bélico de ucrania
este paquete llegó ayer cuál es
exactamente
aquí solo quedan personas valientes y
con coraje su decisión nivel curioso
nada les echará de la ciudad
los ganaremos definitivamente
permanecerán aquí hasta la victoria como
un escudo para ucrania y también para
europa
es difícil predecir si habrá un mañana
si no nos casamos mañana os extrañe
podría pasar algo cualquier día y no nos
casaríamos
la amenaza de muerte se cierne sobre
hard keep que ha sido golpeada día y
noche durante más de 5 semanas
[Música]
anthony nastia no tendrán su luna de
miel pronto
juran quedarse y resistir
mientras la perspectiva de una nueva
ofensiva rusa se cierne sobre su ciudad
[Música]
queremos agradecer a la casa 73 22 por
facilitarnos sus instalaciones para la
realización de este programa ya ustedes
muchas gracias por seguir una nueva
edición de corresponsables nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en francés 24 y france 24
punto com